الان من اسطنبول الاستاذ فراس رضوان اوغلو
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي اهلا بك استاذ
يبدو ان الرئيس اردوغان هو القادر ربما
الوحيد على تحقيق بعض التغيير فيما قد
يسمى بدبلوماسيه الحبوب ما النقاط التي قد
يدفع بها الرئيس اردوغان في هذا اللقاء
بينه ورئيس بوتين
هو يعني الحليف للغرب كونه في عناتو جزء
من المنظومه الغربيه والصديق المقرب ايضا
للرخيص بوتين اذا كان اظن ان هناك دور
اخطرا من الغرب باتجاه الرئيس اردوغان
النقطه الثانيه
ستكون هي البقاء على البحر الاسود هادئا
ولا يوجد لا تريد تركيا زياده الاضطراب
فيه لان ذلك له حسابات اخرى اظن مختلفه
طبعا هي متعلقه في مساله الحبوب والنقطه
الثالثه اوكرانيا نفسها تعتبر ان تركك
وسيط قوي وجيد بينها وبينها ان تكون مع
روسيا كونها تمتلك توازن قوي سواء عسكريا
او دبلوماسيا في هذه النقطه اضافه الى ان
هناك مصالح التركيه هذه النقطه الرابعه
ستتضرر في حال بقاء روسيا على هذا
الموقف اظن في هذا السياق ولذلك ممكن ما
سمعنا من بعض الاطروحات حول اعداد ممكن
تصدير هذه
حبوب الى تركيا ومن تركيا يتم يعني العمل
بها وبعد ذلك تصديرها من تركيا وحسابات من
قطر وغيرها وهذا ان حصل اظن انه واضح انه
من الغرب من الناحيه الماليه على الاقل
لان روسيا كانت تعاني في مساله التحويل
المالي والمشاكل الماليه من تلك الدول
التي تستورد الحبوب الروسيه بالتالي
اخرى
اقترحت بديلا عن هذه الاتفاقيه كيف يمكن
للرئيس اردوغان ان يوفق ربما في هذه
العلاقه المتوازنه بين ربما هذه المطالب
الروسيه وايضا المطلب الاوكراني الغربيه
بالنسبه
للمطلب الروسي اذا اذا كان الامور ستتم
عبر الاراضي التركيه بمعنى ان تتم تصدير
الحبوب الى تركيا او تركيا يتم طحنها او
توزيعها او ما شاء ذلك باتجاه تلك الدول
يعني هنا سيختلف الموضوع ربما ستكون تركيا
كدوله محوله للمال او ربما مستورده لتلك
الدول وتحويلها الى الى روسيا وطبعا لن
يكون هذا الامر دون حسابات بالنسبه
لاوكرانيا
لابد ان تستمر الصادرات الحبوب والزيوت
والى اخره لان تركيا نفسها تستورد كثير من
الحبوب والزيوت النباتيه غير من اوكرانيا
وباسعار مخفضه لذلك يعني تركي نفسها ستكون
متضرر اضافه الى ان اذا استمرت هذه القضيه
البحر الاسود بهذا التوتر يعني سيكون
للناتو ضغوطات اكثر على على روسيا على
تركيا باتجاه ان تكون هناك تداخل تركي مع
الناتو في البحر الاسود هذا ما ترفضه
تركيا بابقاء البحر الاسود بعيدا عن اي
صراعات
من الناتو وروسيا في هذه القضيه لذلك انا
نتوقع اذا نجحت هذه الفكره التي طرحها
الرئيس بوتين
الاخرين
بواسطه ماليه قطريه ايضا بانها تتكلف
بالتكاليف الماليه انا اظن انه حل وسط بين
الاطراف شكرا جزيلا لك فراس رضوان
من اسطنبول شكرا لك